[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich willkommen im Studio
für den Sport Sven Foss schön guten
Abend auch von mir die großen Themen
heute der Kanzler und die bauernproteste
am Rande der Eröffnung eines bahnwerks
geht Olaf Scholz der Konfrontation mit
den Demonstranten aus dem Weg
Israel auf der Anklagebank das Land muss
sich vor dem Internationalen Gerichtshof
verantworten Völkermord in Gaza so der
Vorwurf und traumst vor Rekordkulisse
über 50.000 Zuschauer erleben wie die
deutschen Handballer ihr em Auftaktspiel
klar gegen die Schweiz
gewinnen es ist Tag 4 der Protestwoche
der Landwirte und Landwirtinnen und auch
heute war an vielen Orten in Deutschland
ihr Ärger über die Einsparungen der
Ampelkoalition sichtbar und spürbar so
wie hier in Hannover wo tausende gegen
die geplanten agrarkürzungen
demonstrierten auch in der Mainmetropole
Frankfurt lag teilweise der Verkehr LM
ähnlich das Bild im Hamburger Hafen in
Cottbus nutzen Bauern und Bäuerinnen den
Besuch von Bundeskanzler Scholz in einem
neuen bahnwerk um den Regierungschef
ihren Protest hautner spüren zu lassen
mehr dazu von Alexandra wacano und
Katrin Lindner
der Kanzler ist hier um einen Erfolg zu
feiern das neue ICE bahnwerk hier hat
der Bund investiert hier sollen 1200
neue Arbeitsplätze entstehen so soll der
Strukturwandel in Brandenburg gelingen
vor den Werkstoren ein Traktor nach dem
anderen die Bauern wollen gehört werden
vom Kanzler von ihm im bahnwerk nur so
viel wir leben ja in aufgeregten Zeiten
ein bisschen haben wir das auch gehört
und auch das gehört zur Demokratie dazu
dass man sich seine Meinung sagt aber
hier ist jetzt an dieser Stelle doch zu
sehen wie richtig was vorangeht zu ihnen
ist der nicht gekommen aber Scholz
trifft sich mit dem Chef ihres
Landesverbands der bundeskanz hat noch
mal deutlich gemacht oder welcher
Anspannung der Bundeshaushalt steht das
auf der einen Seite hat sich aber offen
gezeigt für weitere Gespräche weil ich
glaube auch von unserer Seite wurde
deutlich dass wir gerade im letzten Jahr
schon viele Belastungen hinnehmen
mussten deshalb in Frankfurt auch heute
Aktionen oder Hamburg der Protest ginge
über die aktuellen Kürzungen hinaus so
Experten die Bauern hätten
Zukunftsängste sie leiden unter zu viel
Bürokratie
und Auflagen die den Prozess der
ökologischen Transformation prägen in
Form von Chemikalien die sie nicht mehr
einsetzen dürfen in Form von Tierwohl
Vorgaben sie unterstützen den Protest
Handwerker aus Hannover in Weimar auch
dabei Spediteure gegen den Diesel gegen
die co2steuer gegen die Ampel offenbar
gibt es eine gemeinsame
protestformel wir wollen dieses Regime
was uns gängelt was uns Auflagen macht
was von uns permanent neue Leistungen
erwartet nicht weiter bedienen wir
brauchen eine andere Art des Umgangs mit
uns bis mindestens Montag wollen die
Bauern die Republik in Atem halten dann
findet die Großdemo in Berlin statt
Diana Zimmermann wie will die
ampoalition reagieren auf die größer
werdende
Protestbewegung sie signalisiert
Gesprächsbereitschaft der Kanzler hat
den deutschen bauernpräsidenten
getroffen heute den brandenburgischen
die ampelspitzen wollen am Montag acht
Branchenvertreter treffen die Idee ist
reden besser jetzt als nie die Frage ist
aber ob das nun tatsächlich noch hilft
diesen Protest zu mildern abzuschwächen
denn nun wollen sich ja auch Spediteure
Gastronomen Handwerker und Fischer
anschließen ja der Protest wird immer
größer wie sehr steht da auch die
Kommunikation des Kanzlers in der Kritik
der kommunikationssel des Kanzlers ist
ja nicht neu neu ist das ausm Ausmaß der
Wut die ihm
entgegenschlägt und da muss man
feststellen hat beim SPD Parteitag die
Partei ihm noch wirkliche Rückendeckung
gegeben und sich hinter ihn gestellt so
gibt es nun auch erste Stimmen aus der
Fraktion die fordern der Kanzler müsse
mehr und vor allen Dingen empathischer
kommunizieren wohl wissen dass das nicht
seine Stärke ist die Kritik zielt damit
ziemlich direkt auf seine Person und
zeigt dass die ampelvertreter angesichts
der Proteste und der stetig sinkenden
Umfragewerte nervös werden vielen Dank
für diese Einschätzung Diana
Zimmermann und auch diese Entscheidung
der Bundesregierung könnte den nächsten
Wochen für Unmut sorgen alternative
Behandlung etwa Homöopathie sollen bald
keine Kassenleistung mehr
sein für alle Gesundheitsleistung
zusammen haben die gesetzlich en
Krankenkassen nach letzten Daten rund
290 Milliarden Euro gezahlt zum
Vergleich die Kosten für hohmöepartische
und ähniche Behandlungen lagen nur bei
30 bis 50 Millionen größeres
Sparpotenzial also eher Fehlanzeige
dortte
FB Wirkstoffe werden in Wasser
verschüttelt dann in Kügelchen gebracht
solche homöopathischen Arzneimittel
werden von den Kassen bislang teils
erstattet der Gesundheitsminister will
das nun ändern die Homöopathie ist eine
Leistung die keinen medizinischen Nutzen
auf der Grundlage des wissenschaftlichen
Sachstandes erbringt dann sollte eine
solche Leistung auch nicht bezahlt
werden die Krankenkassen sollten nicht
Krankenkassenleistungen bezahlen die
medizinisch nichts bringen das können
wir uns nicht lassen sie hat eine
schulmedizinische Praxis und verordnet
auch homöopathische Mittel ohne die
würde sie ihren Patienten wohl wieder
mehr Antibiotika verordnen sagt die
Internistin und deswegen glaube ich auch
dass diese Aktion die Homöopathie aus
dem erstattungskatalog zu streichen eher
ein Schuss nach hinten ist weil wir dann
wieder höhere Kosten mit normalen
Medikamenten haben werden die Kosten für
homöopathische Arzneimittel sind gering
das Einsparpotenzial für die Kassen auch
das verärgerungspotenzial aber ist groß
badenwürtbergs grüner
Gesundheitsminister teilt mit die
Debatte braucht es gerade wirklich nicht
viele Menschen vertrauen der Homöopathie
weil sie offensichttig gute Erfahrungen
damit machen hingegen sind die Kosten
der Kassen für diese Leistungen marginal
insofern empfinde ich das gerade als
eine scheinheilige Evidenz versus
kostendebatte die nicht angemessen ist
Karl Lauterbach will sparen an der
Homöopathie es bringt ihm wohl wenig
Ertrag und viel
Ärger scharfe Kritik nach Berichten über
ein Treffen von AFD Politikern und
Neonazis der Kanzler sagt wer sich gegen
die freiheitliche demokratische
Grundordnung richtet ist ein Fall für
den Verfassungsschutz und die Justiz die
CDU prüft derzeit ob Mitglieder ihrer
Partei an dem Treffen teilgenommen
hätten sollte dies so sein und viel
spricht dafür werden wir harte
Konsequenzen ziehen sagte CDU
Generalsekretär Linnemann Karl
Hinterleitner
berichtnet die Empörung geht quer durch
politische Berlin anlasst das Treffen
zwischen hochrangigen afdl und
rechtsradikalen Netzwerkern in einem
Hotel in Potzdam im November mit Plänen
Millionen Menschen aus Deutschland zu
vertreiben illegal und klar
verfassungswidrig so die
bundesinnenministerin ich kann ihn noch
nicht im Detail sagen wie wir das
bewerten aber das was wir gesehen haben
was der Verfassungsschutz schon
ausgewertet hat ist völkisches
Gedankengut was dort bei diesem Treffen
vereinbart wurde und deswegen erwarte
ich auch dass alle die da in der Nähe
sich befinden oder das auch nur
annäherend irgendwie gut finden sich
davon distanzieren weil das verstößt
klar gegen unsere Regeln des
Grundgesetzes das aber tun sie
keineswegs ein Bundestagsabgeordneter
der AFD bekräftigt heute auf X vormals
Twitter die AFD sei für massenhafte
Vertreibungen wir werden die Ausländer
in ihre Heimat zurückführen
millionenfach das ist kein Geheimplan
das ist ein Versprechen politische
Beobachter sind alarmiert aber nicht
wirklich überrascht was wir hier erlebt
haben ist eine Enthüllung von der man
eigentlich hätte wissen müssen und
können denn die AFD ist auch wenn Sie
sich jetzt moderater gibt in weiten
Teilen genauso rechtsextrem wieder
Kontakt im Hotel ist gezeigt hat sie
kooperiert mit rechtsradikalen die eines
im Schilde führen eine echte Abschaffung
der Demokratie ein Verbot der AFD sieht
der Justizminister dennoch skeptisch
denn sollte es vor Gericht scheitern
dann droht hier natürlich ein prsieg für
die AFD und dann hätte man am Ende
rechtsradikal es rechtsextremes
rechtsextremistisches zumindest
rechtspopulistisches Gedankengut nicht
bekämpft sondern möglicherweise gestärkt
gegen Extremismus Hilfe letztlich nur
die politische Auseinandersetzung und
mehr dazu erfahren Sie auch in der ZDF
heute live ab 19:30 Uhr im Interview ein
Verfassungsrechtler und eine
Politikwissenschaftlerin
über die Rolle der AFD zu finden auf
unserer Homepage und in der App dort
können Sie auch sehen wer genau zu dem
Treffen eingeladen hat und wer gekommen
ist es ist extrem selten dass Staaten
vor dem höchsten un-gericht dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof in Den Haag
verklagt werden es geht um die Kämpfe in
Gaza mit inzwischen tausenden getöteten
Zivilisten und Zivilistinnen israel muss
sich in diesem Zusammenhang jetzt wegen
Völkermordes verantworten geklagt hat
Südafrika ein Land mit langer
apartheitgeschichte
Entscheidungen des Internationalen
Gerichtshofs sind s zwar bindend können
aber kaum durchgesetzt werden Gunner
Krüger
berichtet die Welt schaut auf Gaza auf
die Zerstörung auf die hohe Zahl ziviler
Opfer es ist Israels Reaktion auf den
Terror der Hamas es sei Völkermord sagt
Südafrika vor dem Weltgericht in den
HA kein beaffneter Angriff auf ein
Staatsgebiet egal wie schwerwiegend
selbst grueltaten rechtfertigen oder
entschuldigen Verstöße gegen die
völkermordkonvention Israels Reaktion
auf den Angriff am 7 Oktober
überschreitet diese
Linie der Internationale Gerichtshof
hier treffen sich Israel und Südafrika
weil beide Unterzeichner sind von der
UN-Konvention zur Verhütung und
Bestrafung von
Völkermord das Zentrale Element dieser
Definition ist die Absicht eine
nationale oder ethnische Gruppe
ganz oder teilweise zu zerstören also
sehr hohe Anforderungen in subjektiver
Hinsicht die entsprechend schwierig
nachzuweisen
sind Südafrika versucht es aus
Solidarität mit Palästina die
zurückreicht in Zeiten der Apartheit und
mit Zitaten Gaza werde nie wieder was es
war man werde alles auslöschen sagt etwa
Israels verteidig
der juristische Wert umstritten Israel
stellt dagegen seine Wahrheit kämpft in
den HA um die Meinung der
Welt heute wurden wir Zeugen einer der
größten Heucheleien der Geschichte
zusammengebaut aus falschen und
grundlosen
Behauptungen Angehörige von Geiseln sind
angereist Botschaft Völkermord das sei
allein die Absicht der
Hamas Michael bewerunger ist für uns in
Tel Aviv Michael wie wird die Anklage in
Israel
aufgenommen also in Israel besteht
breiter politischer Konsens dass dies
ein politischer Prozess ein
propagandaprozess im Sinne der Hamas ist
was nicht heißt dass man die
öffentlichkeitswirksamen Folgen für
Israel nicht mit Sorge betrachtet das
kann man daran erkennen dass Israel
seinen renommiertesten Richter in das
Richtergremium von den Hag berufen hat
Aaron Barak ehemals Präsident des
Obersten Gerichtshofs und Holocaust
Überlebender allein daran schon kann man
erkennen für wie absurd der vorruf des
Genozids angesichts eines wahren
Völkermords gehalten wird Israel
argumentiert innerlich dass es
schließlich die Hamas gewesen sei die
mit ihrem Angriffskrieg gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung Israels den
selbstverteidigungskrieg Israel
aufgezwungen habe dass dabei der Schutz
der Zivilbevölkerung nicht gelungen ist
ist hier ein offenes Geheimnis premier
Netanyahu hat das öffentlich eingeräumt
aber daraus die Absicht für ein Genozid
abzuleiten das wird hier schlicht als
absurd angesehen auch wenn es manche
Äußerung von koalitionsmitgliedern gibt
die das vermuten lassen Präsident
netanahu hat heute jedenfalls noch mal
klargestellt dass es keine Absicht gibt
Israels Gaza dauerhaft zu besetzen oder
gar Palästinenser von dort zu vertreiben
vielen Dank Micha
beberunger der Wind fegt rauer über das
Südchinesische Meer das sagt
bundesaußenministerin berburg bei ihrem
Besuch auf den Philippinen und
kritisiert China scharf es geht um die
immer häufigeren gewaltsam Zwischenfälle
auf hoher See das Problem China
beansprucht große Teile der Meerenge für
sich über die sich zahlreiche
anreinerstaaten wie die Philippinen
versorgen und ein Großteil des
Welthandels abgewickelt wird Andreas
Küst hat die Außenministerin
begleitet
10 000 km ist Deutschlands
Außenministerin geflogen um an diesem
Nachmittag in Manila an Bord des
patrouillenboots Gabriela silang zu
gehen wo die Küstenwache der Philippinen
ihre Exzellenz annaalena bbock
willkommen
heißt wir brauchen mehr sagt der Admiral
und guckt die Frau Außenministerin an
wir brauchen mehr Drohnen wir haben
nicht
genug dann er das philippinische
Seegebiet auf das die Chinesen Anspruch
erheben auf dem sie Inseln okkupieren
und Militärbasen errichten indem sie
Schiffe mit Wasserwerfern vertreiben für
die Vertreterin der drittgrößten
Handelsnation der Welt sind die Angriffe
nicht nur ein asiatisches Problem sie
stellen für Länder weltweit die
völkerrechtlich verbriefte Freiheit der
seeewege in Frage in einem Gebiet durch
das ein Drittel des globalen Seehandels
fließt danach sitzt berbock vor
Präsident Markos der bei Außenministern
immer hinter seinem Schreibtisch bleibt
und sagt die Lieferung weiterer
aufklärungsdrohnen zu es dauert keine
zwei Stunden bis Peking berbock
kritisiert kein Dritter hat das Recht in
Konflikte um das Südchinesische Meer
einzugreifen morgen wird berbock nach
Malaysia Reisen das nächste Land das
sich Hilfe bei der Abwehr von
Gebietsansprüchen
wünscht in Polen haben Anhänger und
Anhängerinnen der Nationalkonservativen
Partei peace die jetzt in Opposition ist
gegen die neue mittellinksregierung
protestiert zetausende Menschen zogen
durch Warschau vor das Parlament ihr
Protest richtet sich auch gegen die
Verhaftung zweier verurteilter Politiker
der peace gestern Präsident duda der der
Partei selbst nahe steht kündigte an die
beiden Verurteilten erneut zu begnaden
nun kommen wir zum Sport sen was war
denn das für ein handballspektakel
gestern ja irre Rekordkulisse zum
auftagt der handbaluropameisterschaft in
Düsseldorf mit über 50.000 Zuschauern
und dann noch eine überragende Leistung
des Gastgebers gegen den ersten
Gruppengegner Schweiz spielten die
deutschen Handballer
furios es lief rund für die DAB Auswahl
und zwar in jeder Hinsicht gegen
indisponiert wirkende
Schweizer
die Leistung besonders der Abwehr und
and die natürlich phänomenal dahinter
mit spektakulären Paraden nahm Andreas
Wolf dem Gegner den Schneid und baute
das eigene Team auf Erfolgsquote
sagenhafte
61%. ich wusste dass an gut ist aber
dass er sowas heute macht das ist von
dem anderen Stern Spielmacher Juri Knorr
war mit sechs Treffern bester Werfer und
fühlte sich wie das gesamte Team von der
Rekordkulisse von
53500 Zuschauern zusätzlich angetrieben
ein 27 Z1 Kanter Sieg als
Durchgangsstation Zugfahrt nach Berlin
der nächste Gegner am Sonntag
nordmazedonien Erfolg auch für die
deutschen Biathleten beim Weltcup in
rupholding sicherte sich die
Männerstaffel um Benedikt doll Platz 2
in einem turbulenten Rennen am Ende kann
sich das deutsche Quartett beim
Heimweltcup dann doch noch über einen
Podestplatz freuen nach dem pazer des
dritten Läufers Benedik doll schießt
zwei Strafrunden fällt die deutsche
Mannschaft zwischenzeitlich zurück auf
Rang 6 dieses richtig schnell schießen
da muss ich einfach ein Tick langsamer
machen und schon noch auf die Treffer
schauen Schlussläufer Philip navrad
schiebt sich beim letzten Schießen vor
auf Rang 2 auch die vierte Staffel in
diesem Winter gewinnen die Norweger
dahinter mit deutlichem Abstand
Deutschland und Italien wird
Dritter und noch ein paar
fußballpersonalien der Wechsel des
englischen Nationalspielers Jaden Sancho
zum BVB ist perfekt der Angreifer kommt
von Manchester United und spielte
bereits 2017 für knapp 4er Jahre bei
Borussia Dortmund und auch der FC Bayern
holt sich Verstärkung aus England
Verteidiger Eric derer ist bereits in
München eingetroffen und der DFB hat
heute seine neue sportdirektorin für den
Frauenfußball vorgestellt die frühere
Nationalspielerin und Weltmeisterin nia
Künzer erhält einen Dreijahresvertrag
nach der WM Enttäuschung für die
deutschen Frauen geht es für Künzer
jetzt darum die Nachfolge von
exbundestrainerin Martina VST
Tecklenburg zu
da gibt viel zu tun Jana danke schön s
lange hat es den Menschen in Norwegen
beim Anblick ihrer vereisten sehen schon
in den Füßen gekrippelt jetzt wurde in
vielen Regionen die amtliche
schlittschuhfahrerlaubnis erteilt
anhaltende minusgade haben für ganz
dickes Eis gesorgt sogar bei den Seen im
eher milderen Westen wie hier am Rand
von Bergen und die Norwegerin und
Norweger Groß und Klein sind kaum zu
bremsen
von naden wird es trüber und milder
örtlich druht Glätte mehr zu den
winterwetteraussichten gleich von Katja
hornfer um 21:45 Uhr gibt's das heute
journal mit Marietta Slomka schönen
Abend
[Musik]
noch guten Abend der sonnige Streifen
über Deutschland der wurde heute übertag
immer schmaler denn Hochnebel und Wolken
zogen weiter südwärts und der Hochnebel
im Alpenvorland löste sich gar nicht auf
jetzt in der Nacht bildet sich zum Teil
wieder Bodennebel und aus diesen
dichteren Wolken hier im Norden da kann
es ein bisschen Drau Niesel etwas
Schneegriesel oder Schnee geben und das
bedeutet Glättegefahr auf Straßen und
Gehwegen denn die Temperaturen sinken
doch meist in den Frost von -1 bis -12°
nur ganz im Nordwesten bleibt es bei 3°
milder dort erwarten uns morgen
Höchsttemperaturen von 3 bis 6° sonst
liegen die Höchstwerte um den
Gefrierpunkt in Norddeutschland ist es
morgen meist drüben es kann auch ein
bisschen regnen etwas freundlicher ist
es Richtung Ostsee und aus diesen
lichten Wolken kann es auch morgen über
Tag noch etwas Schneegriesel und
Nieselregen geben dann bleibt's glatt
auf den Straßen anders sieht es in
Süddeutschland aus zwischen dem beisg
und dem Alpen Vorland scheint die Sonne
zum Teil strahlend am Wochenende wird es
erst im Norden dann auch im Osten und am
Montag dann auch im Südosten für Regen
Schneeregen und Nieselregen reichen mit
leichter Glättegefahr im Südwesten
bleibt es dagegen freundlich guten Abend